hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that was played in 2008 in
the
amber rapids tournament and i've known
about this game for quite a while but
i've never gotten around to covering it
and i'm covering it now so
this is one you're definitely going to
enjoy it features uh many great moments
uh so without further ado let's check it
out
yeah vasily vancouver versus sergey
karakin and vasily opens
with e4 uh we have c5
karakan goes for the sicilian defense
knight f3 d6 and now uh d4 striking in
the center
going for the open sicilian we have
captures captures and knight to f6 so
this is all very standard
knight to c3 and a6 the knight of
defense is on the board
and here bishop to c4 going for the
lipnitsky attack
uh we have e6 and bishop back to b3 so
we've
we're now in into in the souls in attack
variation
uh we have b5 uh now with ideas of uh
dislodging this knife from c3 at some
point maybe putting pressure on e4
bishop to b7 is coming knight here maybe
knight here rook c8 and so on
so here bishop to g5 by white and bishop
to e7
nicely developing uh we have queen to f3
now with some ideas of maybe e5 putting
pressure on the knight and
that brook any uh on a8 and queen to c7
karakan says this is not a problem this
has all been played before
and even in 2008 this has all been
played before
so e5 now attacking the knight and the
rook but
it's not really doing all that much
because bishop to b7
attacks the queen and now comes e
captures on d6 this is a move that has
been played
uh before so it's it's nothing new
and if you're wondering uh there there
are some lines where you can actually
play e
captures on f6 but that's when the
bishop is fiance on g7 and then you know
very interesting stuff happens and it
would help if this bishop was an e2
i think there's a mikhail tal game where
something like this was played and then
bishop captures this bishop captures the
queen and then the bishop also attacks
the rook here and everything is hanging
here
but this is not such a position uh so
here e captures on d6
attacks black's queen and now you can't
just go for traits because after
captures and captures
blacks both of black's pieces are under
attack so this is just completely lost
for black now
so instead after e captures on d6 bishop
capture some d6 is played
and now queen to e3 and again there are
like
70 games in the database with this exact
same position so this is nothing nothing
um
uh you know new here bishop to c5 now
pinning the knight and here queen side
castles by
vasily we have knight to c6 putting more
pressure on d4
and this is the the interesting moment
of the game it seems like
white got pretty much uh
well in a bit of a pickle here
if you would uh you know put it like
that because
it doesn't really uh well it's hard to
say how you would
do anything here but the best probably
for white would be something like bishop
captures g
captures and now once you've removed the
defender of the d5 square just knight d5
and of course this is impossible the
king is still on e8 we're attacking
black's queen
uh this uh with this this would be good
for for both white and black you can
just move the queen or you can even go
for a queen trade with queen to e5
but instead after knight to c6 vasily
went for something else he went for the
move from the thumbnail
and that's queen captures on e6 and even
in 2008
this was not a new idea so the idea is
next
if captures an e6 we have knight
captures on e6
and now you're attacking black's queen
so what can you do here
uh interestingly this position has been
reached in 2010 again
uh with karjakin playing the white
pieces but it was also in the wrap
in the amber tournament but it was in
the blindfold section uh karakin was
playing against
and in that game bishop d6 was played by
gashimov and that game ended in a draw
because well this is just uh a very
solid move you just give back the queen
right away and you're not interested in
any of the white's fancy stuff for
example
captures with check bishop captures the
rook he one check
and now we're just gonna block check and
then the the game continues and it's
it's not easy for black with all of
these lines being uh you know
cut through with with the rooks and the
bishops but
you can hold this another thing you can
do after
such a move that the queen is attacking
you could go queen to e7
but after rook h to e1 there's really no
way of keeping that queen now this is a
threat this is a threat
i mean you you're just not going to be
able to hold it you're going to have to
give up the queen either way for example
captures captures
97 and then the game continues the
difference being now the rook is here
instead of on
e1 but after this knight captures on e6
in this game
uh karakin went for queen to e5 and it
is now as of move 15 that this position
has never been
reached again so how do you continue
here
uh well here vasili starts with knight
captures on g7
and he delivers check we have king to f8
and now
knight back to e6 with check and now the
problem is
if king to e7 then rook h to e1 and
that's just it
you have to play something uh point is
that
if the queen there is one move that uh
that's kind of good here but we're gonna
cover it in uh
uh another another line because it's not
all that easy to spot
but the point is if you move the queen
for example queen f5 then just
let's say knight captures king f8 and
bishop h6 checkmate
there are other lines that uh black can
survive for a few more moves but
they will all end in checkmate except
that one line that we mentioned
so instead we have king to f7 not king
the e7
trying to stay away from that e file but
rook h the e1 all the same here if uh
if vasily wanted he he doesn't have to
rush rook hd1 he could just start
collecting material
knight captures on c5 opens up a
discover check if king g6
we only then capture capture capture and
then uh
uh a knight captures uh on b7 leaving us
uh with this here position and it would
be it would be very unpleasant okay
black does have the queen both rooks and
the knight but
uh with with with both knights the
bishop the the rook say it's not going
to be easy with that king and g6 but
it's it's still a game
uh so instead after king to f7 we have
rook h to e1 right
away by vasily and now comes queen
captures on e1 uh you can't really move
if queen to f5 like we said
uh any weird square just knight captures
the knight d4 delivers a discovery from
the bishop
uh the queen is lost so here instead uh
sergey decided to give back the queen we
have queen captures on e1
and this is a bit of a problem
uh because instead of this move there is
one move that you could have played
to kind of uh survive in this
whole whole game altogether but it's not
very easy to find so feel free to pause
the video
and try to find this great move for
karjakin while i give you a couple of
seconds
is the same move that i've mentioned in
that other line
so uh no i i do not have a cat for this
video the cat
left uh so for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
it's bishop captures an f2 so also
congratulations to everyone who founded
bishop captures an f2 and this is a
crucial move
because now after the queen is captured
we have knight captures and now okay you
have to
grab some material you have to use this
discovery knight
38 a double check from the knight and
the bishop and once the king moves you
have to move with temple you have to
attack this bishop
knight captures on b7 or rather uh
battery at bishop captures on f6 first
and then after king captures now we
capture on b7 makes more sense
and now we play this uh end game where
well we are uh we are up two points
we're down the exchange but we're up two
pawns and we are very happy here however
uh black uh does not have any worries
here this is also perfectly fine for
black so this is the move that should
have been played however uh sergey
played the queen capture sunny one and
now
uh it's pretty much the same thing only
you don't win the pawn
so unfortunately but it's a rapid game
okay you can't see everything
like it was if it was a classical game
so knight captures
with a discovery we have king to g6 now
rook captures on e1
king captures on g5 and now knight
captures on b7
so the material is equal like uh in the
line that we've shown only
the f2 pawn still is intact so this is
now
a pretty big problem with three three
connected pawns here
uh but okay it's up to karakin to try
and hold this we have knight to d4
now putting pressure on the light square
bishop and knight to d6 shifting the
knight back into the game
uh we have rook h to f8 now hoping to
to do some damage along this f file but
just f3 taking care of this knight so
controlling both of these squares
and also the pawn will not no longer be
a target on f2 we have b4
uh pushing back this knight knight to e4
with check we have captures cap
not capture so rook captures uh instead
now
cutting off the king from going in any
deeper into the position
and now comes knight captures on b3 with
check we have eight captures and now a5
preparing
a4 so here rook the g4 with
check king to f6 and now knight to e4
all right we have king to e5 and now
rook to h4 so if you look at the
position now
karakin is up the exchange but he's down
three pawns and that's a lot
if the f pawn wasn't here he'd be only
down two points
and he wouldn't have problems uh using
the df file
like he has now and here doesn't really
matter you can't really defend this pawn
if you try something like rook to f7
just
rook h5 check if king of four king d2
now you have to worry about something
like king e2 and g3
uh ending the game on the spot so
instead we have
a4 by kyrekin now trying to do some
damage on the queen side
but now b captures on a4 rook captures
and now knight the c5 attacking the rook
and also if
black is not careful knight d7 check is
coming then you're going to lose the
other rook as well
so rook to a1 check moving with tempo
king d2 and then now
rook to g8 attacking the g2 pawn of
course vasily will defend this
g3 and now uh rook to f1 putting
pressure on the f3 pawn and just the
calm king to e2
defending and attacking so rook back to
b1
and now it's not really even a threat
this you you can never capture this if
white wanted white could just capture
here
and then if you capture again this is
just uh you know a nice fork you
you lose the game so rook to b1 not
really
doing all that much but still rook
captures on b4 was played
just to be extra safe king to d5 and now
knight to e4 and now as you can see it's
five points to one and this is
this is a pretty big deal king to c6 we
have
h4 now now slowly but surely vasily will
start pushing pawns on both sides of the
board we have rooked the h1
and now rook to c4 with check king to b6
and now finally b4 we start pushing
those pawns
rook to d8 and now rook to c5 grabbing
more space we have rook to a8 and now
c3 uh we have uh rook to a2 with
check king e3 rook the one check uh
nah yeah not this one was ivan czech
king f4
and now rook to f1 but white really has
no worries in the world here
rook to h5 going after the last pawn and
now rook to a8 you don't really get
anything by rook to a7 defending we can
just add another attacker knight here
pick up the pawn
it doesn't really matter so rook to h6
with check first
king b5 and now knight to d6 with
check not allowing king to c4 so you you
keep
both of the pawns king to a4 and now
rook captures on h7 and now
uh vasily is up five pawns so here king
b3
and rook the c7 now uh okay you know
taking care of every pawn not allowing
uh
black any counter play we have rook to
d8 attacking the knight and here
uh wassily just played a knight to f5
and it was in this position on mu 49
that sergey karakin resigned in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh i will show you how the game might
have continued because i know a lot of
you enjoy that but
there's really no no point in black
continuing because the pawns are just
too strong for example
if rook d3 going after the pawn here
you're just gonna play knight to d for
check and after the king moves let's say
king b2 now you're just going to start
pushing
h5 and you don't really care everything
is nicely defended
uh black's only move is to capture this
point but you really don't carry it at
this point captures captures and
captures you're gonna play knight f5
and then just push that pawn king
captures on b4 we're gonna push this
pawn
if rook h1 defending it just g4 and that
i mean there's no counter play here g5
whatever black plays king c6 you can't
go go here uh g6 and that's
just it there there's no stopping those
pawns so of course sergey knew this and
after knight to f5 he resigned the game
and
uh a brilliant brilliant victory for
vasily evan chuck
in this uh 2008 uh amber tournament and
also i forgot to mention this this is a
suggestion
by an excellent subscriber kartik sharma
so thank you for that
i really appreciate uh like i said i
know of this game but i know of many
games that i still haven't had a chance
to cover
so you know a hashtag suggestion always
helps
so yeah a really awesome stuff uh vasily
was not able to win the tournament uh
the tournament was won by levan arnon
who had an amazing amazing streak i
think he wanted with a one and a half
point ahead of everyone else but vasily
did get second place and third place was
shared between
uh magnus carlsen abortion fund
and uh peter lakoe so
really really awesome stuff thank you
for suggesting me this game really
enjoyed it and it's
i mean it is just something incredibly
incredibly aesthetically pleasing when
you see a move like
queen captures on e6 i mean it's just uh
there are a few squares where where a
queen sacrifice
is as good okay a queen sacrifice on f6
for example
is very good but uh queen queen e6 is
just
really really awesome if you remember
we've shown a game not
so long ago i think maybe maybe last
month uh where
alejan uh sacrificed that queen on e6
the bishop was on d3 and then the bishop
delivers checkmate i don't know if you
if you guys remember that
if you don't i will put a link to it in
the description below first first link
uh first thing you will see it's uh 11
moves long so if you haven't seen it
you're not gonna be sorry
but yeah i hope you guys enjoyed it uh i
would like to thank brandon martel
[ __ ] software art and science of
kinesiology llc
uh lucinda time uh ciao antonio and
francesco dude
uh dundee car for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga checking up
on your one of the suggestions and
whatever else happens uh in the chess
world
and by whatever happens i mean the
candidates tournament starts in three
days
thank you all and i will see you soon